in the opening scene we are introduced
to June a young boy who lives in an
orphanage his parents died in a car
accident some years back and that's how
he's ended up here June finds solace in
his passion for drawing considering it a
means to keep negativity at Bay and
bring happiness into his life alongside
his artistic talent June also possesses
impressive fighting abilities he shows
us a small demo by successfully
defeating a 9th grade student it is
revealed that he inherited this trait
from his father who is a former National
level Taekwondo player one evening a
chief agent affiliated with National
Intelligence service named diak Yu pays
a visit to the orphanage aware of June's
fighting prowess diakyu aims to train
and recruit him as an undercover agent
he encourages June to Aspire for
greatness and follow in his Father's
Footsteps by contributing to the nation
from that point forward June embarks on
his training gradually developing into a
formidable fighter and earning the
prestigious title of an elite assassin
but despite all this June remains
committed to his passion for drawing he
is always making sketches even when on
dangerous missions one day June is
assigned a mission to apprehend Simon a
fugitive and the younger brother of a
notorious criminal named Jason June
easily manages to capture Simon alive
and during the subsequent interrogation
the National Intelligence service also
known as the NIS discovers that Jason
has recently departed Busan by Shep a
few moments later a talented newcomer to
the NIS named Chile enters the scene to
receive training on criminal
interrogation techniques however before
they can delve further into the matter
Simon passes away due to the gruesome
torture not very good Training for chill
following this diakyu orders June to
eliminate Jason with utmost urgency
without any delay June gears up and
Boards a helicopter that is Bound for
Jason's ship upon reaching the specified
area he bravely leaps from the
helicopter but unfortunately fails to
deploy his parachute resulting in a
dangerous fall into the sea in the
aftermath of this incident June is
presumed dead leading his team to gather
and offer a final tribute his honor
however their assumption proves to be
incorrect as it is revealed that June is
actually alive in a surprising turn of
events June seems to have staged his own
death to abandon his role as an
undercover agent and pursue a career as
an artist the story then fast forwards
by 15 years where June has become a
webtoon artist was it really worth it to
June he is currently married to a
hard-working woman named Mina and they
have a nine-year-old daughter guy young
at first glance it appears as if they
are living happily but things are quite
different from the inside June is
struggling badly at work and he is
always under constant pressure to meet
his editors deadlines he is also
subjected to negative comments that
undermine his confidence this has
resulted in a serious lack of finances
at home but despite his shortcomings his
wife remains devoted to him and supports
him in every way possible she works
double shifts while June takes care of
all the household chores including
cleaning cooking and preparing their
daughter for school he also secretly
works at a construction company to
support the family currently June is
working on a comic project that is not
meeting expectations much like his
previous Works however the consequences
this time around are dire as his editor
demands that he conclude the comic in
the very next episode due to the
reader's lack of Interest June pleads
for an opportunity to continue as he
needs the money but his police fall on
deaf ears that evening feeling dejected
June sits in front of the television
with a drink and reflects on his
declining life frustration overwhelms
him to the point where he begins writing
a comic that vividly recounts his own
past including intricate details of his
journey as an undercover agent the
following morning June awakens to a
surprising change in his wife's demeanor
as she prepares breakfast she informs
him that she thoroughly enjoyed his
recently written comic and took the
initiative to publish it on his behalf
she proudly shares the positive comments
from readers who have shown great
enthusiasm for the comic this Revelation
sends June into a state of panic as he
never intended to divulge any details
from his past especially the sensitive
and confidential information it contains
worried June hurdly rushes to the
editor's office pleading to retract the
published comic he insists that he only
wrote it while under the influence of
alcohol however the editor adamantly
refuses citing The public's appreciation
and enjoyment of the work in the next
scene as June returns home dejected it
suddenly begins raining concerned that
his daughter guy young did not carry an
umbrella he heads to her school to pick
her up while waiting outside he observes
guy Young's friends being collected by
their affluent parents in luxurious cars
this site deeply affects him as he
realizes his inability to provide even a
piano for his daughter hence June
ultimately makes the decision to create
further narratives based on his past
experiences he writes thrilling accounts
of capturing notorious criminals as well
as his exploits as an elite assassin
with the publication of these news
stories the comics rapidly spread across
the internet capturing the interest of a
wide audience including Mina's
colleagues guy Young's classmates June's
editor and numerous children in the town
as time goes by the family gradually
manages to overcome their financial
crisis as a result June finally fulfills
his daughter's long-standing Desire by
purchasing a piano for her however along
with greater success comes greater
challenges elsewhere diakyu visits a
cybernet facility in order to conduct an
investigation but he has taken aback
when he comes across two children who
possess extensive knowledge about the
secret missions of the National
Intelligence service this includes
classified information regarding the
training provided to underage children
and molding them into merciless
assassins curious about the source of
their information the argue engages the
children in conversation and discovers
that it all stems from the recent viral
Comics upon going through them he is
astonished to learn that the comics even
have the real names of the NIS agents
and the criminals June is going to wind
up on the podium at the Darwin Awards
later awari diakyu holds an emergency
meeting with the NIS officials during
their discussion they reach a startling
conclusion June the highly skilled
former agent renowned for his
extraordinary drawing abilities is alive
and is responsible for exposing the NIS
through the medium of his Comics
concerned about the potential
repercussions for the nation the
director of the NIS hyung do tasks a
team with locating and apprehending June
that evening a grown-up chill and hyung
do visit the editor's office to gather
information about June's whereabouts
seeing the government officials storming
his office the editor gets scared and
immediately divulges that June has been
working part-time at a construction site
shortly after the NIS agents arrive at
the settle location and Surround June
however our hero using his extraordinary
skills manages to subdue each of the
agents without much effort he then
quickly returns home and prepares to
leave the country for this he also calls
his wife and informs her of the
situation however Mina fails to
comprehend his message and assumes that
he is intoxicated prompting her to
abruptly end the call within moments the
NIS agents break into June's residence
launching an attack against him in the
midst of the chaos chiol removes his
mask revealing his face to June June is
taken aback to see him again which
creates a momentary distraction that
allows the NIS to incapacitate him
before taking him into custody back at
the editor's office the main villain
Jason and his accomplices show
seeking information about June's
whereabouts meanwhile at NIS
headquarters June undergoes
interrogation regarding the comic he
claims that he murdered accidentally
while in a state of drunkenness however
young doe remains skeptical and calls
him a traitor shortly after June
receives a distressing call from his
wife and learns that she is being held
captive by some kidnappers they are none
other than Jason's man Jason threatens
June to come over to his Hideout along
with diak gu if he fails to do so within
the next hour his wife will be executed
worried about the safety of his family
June reluctantly agrees to comply in a
calculated move he pretends to confess
everything and calls diocu for the same
but at an opportune moment he launches a
sudden attack on diakyu successfully
retrieving his gun and holding him at
gunpoint using this leverage June
escapes from the NIS headquarters and
heads towards the kidnappers on Route he
explains the entire predicament to diak
Gil the next scene portrays a thrilling
car chase between June and the NIS
agents after a period of evasion June
enters a town tunnel where he knocks
down the agents who are pursuing him
before resuming his Escape shortly after
one of Jason's henchmen arrives at the
scene and eliminates the agents to
ensure that they are not being tracked
then hyung doe and his team reach the
tunnel only to discover the lifeless
bodies of their agents this leaves them
to believe that June is the one who
killed all of them furthermore hyungdo
learns that Jason is in the same town
feeling his belief that June is
collaborating with him to take down NIS
consumed by anger hyungdo kidnaps guy
Yang and uses her as a leverage to force
June out the plan works and as soon as
June receives the news he changes his
Direction and heads towards his daughter
along the way he contacts Jason assuring
him that he will return once he rescues
his daughter from NIS custody however
Mina misunderstands her husband's
intentions believing that he has
abandoned her this causes her immense
pain so she grabs a few bottles of
alcohol present in the room and drinks
them on the other hand sheol having
reservations about harming a child
feigns taking guy young to the restroom
and seizes the opportunity to escape he
then sends a text message to June
summoning him to a meeting location and
awaits his arrival however it turns out
to be a trap as chill confronts June at
gunpoint demanding his surrender
fortunately they are able to clarify the
misunderstanding and diakyu updates
Jewel on June's current predicament with
everything sorted out they agree to team
up and head to rescue Mina before
proceeding to confront Jason they make a
stop at June's former residence which
chill now uses as a storage place for
weapons there they gather some necessary
supplies but before they leave they hear
the NIS approaching thinking quickly
June delivers a series of powerful
punches to chill and asks him to pretend
that he lost him along the way in their
haste June and diakyu inadvertently
leave the bag containing the weapons
behind shortly after hyung doe and his
troops arrive at the scene and discover
the abandoned bag of weapons this leads
young notably of the June is planning to
initiate a war against the NIS although
she all tries to convince him otherwise
hyung doe remains adamant in his stance
meanwhile June diakyu and Guy young
reached Jason's Hideout June and diak Yu
step outside while the little girl
remains in the car secretly recording
their actions before sending the footage
to chill upon viewing it hyungdo and his
soldiers traced the location and set off
towards the hideout on the other hand
Jason and June finally come face to face
the latter asks for the release of his
wife and Jason's henchmen bring her out
in a heavily intoxicated form however
before allowing the couple to depart
Jason demands that June inflict the same
torture upon diagyu as he did to Simon
left with no other option June
reluctantly agrees but even this fails
to satisfy Jason in a cruel twist he
grabs a flamethrower and begins to
unleash Flames upon diagio it appears as
if the poor man is going to meet a
horrible death but right then the NIS
agents Storm Into The Hideout sparking a
fierce shootout between the two factions
diacus probably still dead though after
holding Jason and his men at gunpoint
hyung doe commands his soldiers to
eliminate June in a desperate attempt to
defend him Mina and Jack you intervene
but hyung do remains Resolute he issues
a final order to his sniper who then
takes aim at June but as the shot is
fired she'll surprisingly leaps in front
of June and takes the hit on his
shoulder at that moment Jason's
right-hand man who is positioned on a
higher Vantage Point opens fire on the
NIS agents fearing for the safety of his
family and friends June retrieves a gun
and aims at the enemy sniper but Jason
shoots him multiple times and sends him
crashing to the ground Nina and Guy
young are devastated witnesses to this
tragic scene in the aftermath of the
event Jason holds the remaining NIS
agents hostage it appears as if all hope
is lost but in a remarkable turn of
events June astonishingly Rises to his
feet having been wearing a double layer
of bulletproof vest swiftly he grabs a
gun and detonates a gas tank creating a
diversion to distract Jason's man this
Sparks a fierce brawl between Jason's
henchmen and the NIS agents in the midst
of the chaos June approaches Mina and
guyang offering them his bulletproof
vest for their safety and apologizing
for concealing his past following this
she all engages in combat with a group
of Jason's henchmen diag you faces
Jason's right-hand man and June goes
after the main villain meanwhile the
coward hyungdo takes cover beneath the
body of a fallen soldier leveraging his
exceptional fighting skills June manages
to throw Jason out of a window killing
him brutally with this he fulfills the
final mission which he had abandoned 15
years ago kinda sad that the other
agents weren't able to catch him in all
that time in the final scene we are
shown that June and his family are now
living peacefully far away from the
world of crime and Terror one day she
all pays a visit to him urging him to
rejoin the NIS but June politely
declines the offer choosing to pursue
his dream as a webtoon artist just as he
is always just as he had always
envisioned subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching